actually I actually love this man but
who doesn't
he is my comic relief and I am delighted
and proud to introduce him as Academy
Award winner mr. Robin Williams
brought to you by Viagra
thank you Snoopy it's a wonderful money
before I bring out guns and Moses with
Charlton Heston
but I know you can't say Moses it's the
artist formerly known as the Prince of
Egypt
I'd like to make you aware in case there
is an emergency we have to follow a
kateri protocol Steven Spielberg first
the rest of you on your own okay now I'd
like to say a brief brief word about
artists rights last week Jack Valenti
went to China to talk about copyright
infringement and he gave an impassioned
incredible speech and if anybody wants a
bootleg copy I have one right here
so please and in terms of the Kazan
controversy let Lainey sing thank you
and now in the words is to rest just
alone you know the drill here we go the
nominees I'm here to honor five
extraordinary women for their
performance in the supporting role and
the nominees for Best Supporting Actress
are port always happy Kathy Bates in the
primary color Brenda Blethyn
little voice judi dench Shakespeare in
Love
Rachel Griffith in Hilary and Jackie
Lynn Redgrave in God's and monster
this is very exciting I feel like Adam
when he said to Eve back up I don't know
how big this gets
there is nothing like a dame the Oscar
goes to Dame Judi Dench
first off for Dame Judi Dench who was
last year for her
and mrs. Brown
I feel for eight minutes on the screen I
should only get a little bit of him I do
think they academy very much lead I do
think also that the best fit about the
Academy Awards is being nominated you
live in a kind of haze for several weeks
and the terrible thing is that
somebody's got to win my heart goes out
to the other four who didn't I might
also my admiration I do have to thank
John Madden and Tom Stoppard and Mark
Norman as I actually wrote to John
Madden after mrs. Brown and said I will
do anything in your next film if you
want somebody to slouch in a doorway you
can count on me and I mean it and I hope
you bears been in my next time I do
thank you all very much indeed I'm very
moved by